[music playing]
NARRATOR: Edfu, Egypt,
located on the Western bank
of the Nile.
The temple of Edfu is one
of the largest and most
well-preserved temples
of the ancient kingdom
dating back to 237 B.C.
The Edfu temple is of
tremendous importance.
As you enter the
temple, it's like you're
going inside a book.
It's literally full of texts.
Every wall, every column,
every room, every chamber
is filled with texts.
They're known collectively
as Edfu texts.
What is very interesting is
that the majority of these texts
speak about the
creation of the world.
NARRATOR: According
to the texts,
the Earth was created by
powerful gods who came down
from the sky, and these gods
first established a place
known as the island of the egg.
Two gods they created
an island in the middle
of the eternal lake.
Creation started
with that island.
The occupants of this
so-called primordial mythical
world, very strange creatures.
There seems to be three
groups of people--
one called the sages,
one called the builders,
and the other
called the shebtiu.
Nobody knows who they are.
These are the ones that are
very mysterious because they are
said to emerge from the water.
Then the Egyptians
believed a series of gods
came and built
the first temples.
It says that here the
first temples were built,
the first ones ever in
the world and that these
became the blueprint for
every temple in Egypt.
Once all the creator gods have
done their job with creating
the world, they would
meet with their big bird
and ascend to the sky.
Ancient Egyptians believed
with all their heart
that everything listed and
inscribed on these walls
are true, true, true.
If the walls say there's an
island in the middle of nowhere
where gods would go
and ascend to the sky,
then ancient Egyptians,
the devoted ones,
would believe that
island exists.
NARRATOR: According to the Edfu
texts, not all of the occupants
left.
And after many
generations, the island
suffered a terrible fate.
The texts are very
different as to what
happens to the occupants.
These strange
gods, they seem to,
once they have set the scene,
once they they've built
the temples, they
hand over their work
to the historical lineage.
And then they depart.
We don't know where they go.
There seems to be something
very interesting here.
There seems to be
a war going on.
The armies of these divinities
is led by this falcon God,
and he battles a kind of
enemy represented by a snake.
In the skies appeared what
was known as the enemy snake.
It had a name.
It was called the
Great Leaping One,
and it was said that
immediately it appeared
there was a time of darkness.
And there was some
big floods that
destroyed this sacred island.
And when the waters receded,
these original beings,
who were known as the ancient
ones or the elder ones,
were now no longer there.
Perhaps the Great Leaping
One, this enemy snake,
was the memory of the
comet that entered
into our inner solar
system, broke up, causing
devastation and destruction.
NARRATOR: Might the account
of this ancient catastrophe
inscribed on the walls
of the Edfu temple
be describing a natural event
or was it a deliberate attack,
an attack targeting
an other worldly
civilization existing
on what we now know
as the Antarctic continent?